All right. I haven't made music in 2
weeks. Recently, my wife and I just took
a trip to the West Coast and it was
awesome. I didn't touch any music, so
I'm ready to come back and make
something now. I've been making music on
this channel for a while now. And I've
kind of stayed in this one lane of like
indie pop, indie folk, indie this, indie
that. Uh, I'm ready to just switch it up
and really just step outside of my
comfort zone. I've been seeing this
really insane plugin on Instagram called
the Nudastor. Yes, New Distort did send
this plugin over for me to create with,
but I asked them to because I was like,
"This thing is freaking awesome." I've
seen most people sort of do the McGee
thing with it, which don't get me wrong
is really, really cool, but for this
song that I want to make today, I want
to take it in a little bit of a
different direction. I love Royal Blood.
I love Jack White. I love Foss. So, I
think that this plugin would be fun to
try to just really push it to the limit
and get as dirty of a sound as possible.
And of course, link to the new distort
will be in the description. Definitely
check it out. I think it's one of my
favorite distortion plugins I've ever
used. I feel like I can't call it a
distortion plugin. I feel like that's
kind of an understatement cuz it's much
much more than that. You'll see. So,
yesterday I recorded two quick voice
memos of just an idea that popped in my
head. So, this is the first one here.
>> The drum beat is like
and like just a really gnarly.
Wow. Cool song, man. And then later I
had another idea for a guitar part.
So, you get the idea. But for this, I
just want some really heavy distorted,
like overly distorted drums to start, I
think. And I'm not going to worry too
much about a performance. I'm just going
to get something really general down so
I can structure out my song. I tend to
structure my songs horizontally first
before building them out too far
vertically. That way, I have a finished
product really before I add the
production onto it. For drums, I'm using
this kit I put together in Addictive
Drums 2. I call it my nuke kit.
This is a kit I put together a while ago
to get that like just really clipping
heavy sound.
Let's just start with that for now and
then just see where we go with the
structure. Right. Let's go ahead and
open up new distort. And already
you hear how it's not like a traditional
distortion, right?
Oh, such a gnarly sound. So, you have
two sides to it. First, you have the
distort side with all different types
and modes here. A mix knob. See, that's
the thing. Like,
that's not even with the distortion
blended in. What if we blend it in
there?
It's so freaking gnarly, dude. What
happens if we crank the drive up?
That might be a little too much. Grain.
What does that sound like? So, this is
grain off.
Let's turn it up.
All right. What about damping?
We also have these global parameters
down here where you know if I turn the
tone all the way to the right
get something very bright. If I turn it
all the way to the left
is something very dark. I genuinely
don't know what this symbol is. But what
happens if we turn it up?
Then we have a delay over here, which
also there's a little random dice to
where I can just hit it and get
something different every time.
So yeah, there's so many different
sounds that we can get here. And this
delay, I mean, is like it's your normal
delay, but what makes it cool is this
abnormality.
So yeah, this just a normal delay there.
If we turn the abnor
abnor abnormality
up
starts to play a little funky.
So, this plugin is one of the funnest
plugins I've ever got to play with. Uh,
but I'm going to start out with this
preset called really quite fat. This is
probably my favorite preset in the whole
plugin cuz it's just like
it just has a lot of spunk to it. And
I'm going to turn up this little law
here. Let's just record a little bit of
that guitar so we can start structuring
out the song, right?
All right. So, structure-wise, maybe
just have a guitar intro here.
So, something I do when I'm trying to
write something that's just inspired by
an artist, I try to think of what that
artist would do here. So again, if it's
Jack White, uh, I think there's going to
be a lot of space in here. So if I
approach this next bit like Jack
Whitewood, I think it would be something
like this.
Or maybe we can bring it down.
You know, I'm not going to lie. I don't
really know if I'm feeling this groove
that much. When I first set out my
references, I want to make something
like Troubles Coming by Royal Blood,
2001 by Fos, and then Take Me Back by
Jack White. And I think I want to
actually move somewhere in that
direction instead of like the original
demo. Maybe I'll save this for another
time, but I'd rather do something
different.
I just rather do something fun and
something that's not like, I don't know,
dragging on a little bit. Let's go back
to the drums and restructure this.
Oh, I like that 10 times better.
Oh yeah, that's the one. Maybe it starts
with some kind of like drum intro and
then we have kind of like a lowfi
distorted guitar that's doing that.
That'd be cool if the drums in this part
broke from, you know, that straight
to like,
man, I'm clipping like crazy. Are the
drums really that loud? So, like maybe
for this guitar part, just something
super super simple.
And then a second verse, second chorus,
and then we'll do like a solo. What if
we did like a halftime solo
or just like a really expressive drum
part through here?
Damn it.
Ooh, that was a rough one.
This song is so ridiculous. Oh, and then
you know what we do? Just totally take
it as heavy as possible.
And for this last part, just like all
the way four on the floor.
Yeah. All right. So, that's my
structure. I think this is going to be a
pretty fun song. Uh, let's go ahead and
start with drum production, I think. All
right. I think for the drum beginning, I
know I want to start with like kind of
like the troubles coming lowfi drum
intro that's basically just like the
overhead in the room, I think.
And then we're going to come in with
like a big tom and a snare hit here.
It's also kind of has some like Queens
of the Stone Age a little bit too.
Actually, real quick, just to make it
feel a little fuller, I'm going to
duplicate this track and then transpose
it down a whole octave. So now I have
like a bass that goes along with it.
All right, this verse is going to be a
little tricky, I think.
Should I go open with that high hat?
Yeah, I'm going to go open with that
high hat.
It's like my fingers are frozen today.
It's crazy what not playing music for a
couple weeks will do to you. I need to
take this watch off cuz I honestly think
it's weighing me down a little bit.
Right here. I want to do some kind of
crazy fill, I think.
All right. And then for the second
verse, I think I want to close that
energy up a little bit.
I want to kind of get like the uh
honestly the drum beat is inspired by
what's that Beyonce song.
So I want to get like that kind of vibe
in there, you know?
Too sloppy. Too sloppy.
Oh, if I could quantize that, that would
be like golden, man. Holy smokes.
Well, that was weird. I kind of like I
think that was a mess up with the MIDI,
but it's kind of cool. And then just go
rampage on the ending here.
And I'll have all the I'll have all the
guitars accent on that last little bit.
All right, I think drums are done. Let's
move on to guitars.
Oh, what was the chords here?
Oh,
I messed up that last part there.
All right, I think I'm going to lay down
the bass track, which for the bass, I'm
just going to use this guitar, transpose
it down an octave, and really just layer
it in there.
Oh my gosh.
Ooh, I'm making cheap mistakes now. It's
okay.
Yeah, I'm making really cheap mistakes.
Like, I'm not even paying attention to
the song. I have been going at it like
for two hours straight now without
really taking a break. So, if I keep
messing up, I think I'm just going to
take a quick break.
Sheesh.
And for the bass, I think I'm going to
do uh one channel distorted and just
with a lot of that low end cut out
because I still want there to be some
grit. And then the other one is just
going to be like purely DI just pure
bass tone there.
So this is
too much obviously. Let's see if there's
any like other effects that we can apply
over that.
Sort of like that.
And then this one, we'll run it through
this base DI box here in Logic.
Man, listening through just one time,
like this is a really fun song and
there's not a lot going on. I really
tried to focus the interaction between
the guitar and the drums, so they're
speaking the same language. They're kind
of playing off of each other a little
bit versus just like riff and drums, you
know? By the way, if you want a mix and
production breakdown where I go through
every single decision, every single
plugin, so you can see exactly how I got
everything to sound the way it is, you
can head over to my Patreon. We also do
feedback on your music, some bonus
content. It's a fun place to hang
around. Link is in the description.
Also, if you are looking for help with
your productions, I actually run the
music production boot camp, which is a
12-week academy designed to transform
the way that you create. It's 12 weeks
of lessons, one-on-one mentoring,
homework with feedback, a community, and
live group calls weekly. It's a really
fun place to be. So far, we have like
20some students in there. I have four
spots available as we speak. So, if
you're interested in that, again, link
is in the description. But I think I'm
going to go take a quick break from this
song. Uh because I need to I think my
brain's a little flustered and I want to
give this song some space so I can think
about how I can start adding the weird
production stuff and I also have to
write the freaking thing. So I will see
you in a minute. Real quick, I don't
think I made it apparent enough, but
taking these breaks and literally
stepping outside is so vital to my
creative process and what I do and I
think it can be vital to yours as well.
you know, you're not really getting a
break if you stay cooped up in your
studio and you just go on your phone or
go on YouTube or anything like that.
Like, if you're going to give yourself a
break, give yourself like a proper
break. Step outside. Don't listen to
music. Just embrace silence. Pretty much
the opposite of what I'm doing right
here talking to a camera, but I'm going
to put the camera down and I'm just
going to soak up the sun. Enjoy the
noise of the birds. You know, that
silence that you give yourself is so so
valuable. And I think in today's world,
we don't really get enough of it. It's a
little uncomfortable at times, you know,
to kind of sit there in the silence of
things and not hear anything and being
alone with your thoughts sometimes, but
I promise the more you do it, the more
you'll get used to it and the better
it'll feel, of course. So, I'm going to
sit in silence here for a minute, then
I'm going to get back to the song.
All right. So, I think I'm going to add
vocals. I went ahead and wrote uh just
some pretty simple vocals. I mean, I
think the focus for the song isn't on
the lyrics. Um, but I definitely want to
consider them. I definitely want them to
feel like they belong. Um, I feel pretty
good about what I've written. I'm sure
some people will think it's a little too
uh bland, a little too generic, but
that's okay cuz I mean, I'm really
enjoying the song no matter what. So,
that's not anything anyone on the
internet can take from me. For these
vocals, I'm going to try this broken up
voc preset from my alternative rock uh
logic preset pack. So, let's just see
what happens.
I'm done trying to pretend.
I'm running from what I feel the most.
I'm running fast, but it's getting
close.
>> I'll be honest, singing this is very
uncomfortable. My wife is home working,
so it's like when you're, you know, 16
and recording something in your bedroom
and you don't want your parents to hear
it.
Sort of same vibes right now. But
really, the higher vocals is only in
these two parts. So, if I can just nail
these two parts, then we'll be good.
Maybe I try some of the other vocals
first. Get a little more warmed up.
Getting far and behind.
I got no safety on the deep end.
I'm done trying to
Maybe I need to take it one line at a
time.
>> I
feel the most.
I want it fast, but it's getting close.
I got no safety on the deep.
I'm done trying to pretend.
I'm running, but I feel the most.
I'm running fast, but it's getting
close.
>> Oh, yeah. That helped it out a lot, I
think. Okay, so that feels pretty good
for vocals, I think. I don't know. I'm
going to go ahead and move back to
guitar so I can do some auxiliary
effects. Uh, do the solo as well. But
other than that, I mean, this song is
pretty close to being done, I think.
like it's where I want it to be, which
is pretty cool.
Holy smokes. Yeah, I'm just going to do
that for the solo. That's very, very
Jack White.
I think I just got to remove the noise
gate and just let it
just let that interference come through.
Triple track. Triple check the last part
of that solo.
So that's so crazy gnarly. I think I'm
going to add some more guitars, but just
kind of uh a little thicker and lower
sounding. Like I mean just tone all the
way down.
The
This is sounding massive, dude. What if
I added a high guitar to the end of
that, too?
Yeah, that belongs. I think I'm going to
do one that's two octaves up, too. Just
one, maybe. It might It might be too
much, but it just might be cool.
Holy smokes. So, just to show you a
comparison from what it was before
adding all these layers, uh, it started
off as this.
and ended up as this.
Dude, that is crazy.
I don't care what anybody thinks of this
song in the comments. I don't care. I'll
be honest with you guys. Some of the
last videos that I've done, I've really
let the comments get to me. Um, and I've
really let that feed into my uh artistry
and my worth as an artist. But the joy I
feel from making this song, not even the
final result of the song, but the joy I
feel from making it in the process that
I have, nobody can take that away from
me right now because I am so happy with
this wall of sound here. I'm so happy
with this. I just kind of want to go
through the presets and see if there's
like any cool atmosphere that I can
make. And actually, I'm going to try
this one. Shane Becker. I'm a big fan of
his work. Uh he has this preset called
There's No Way That You'll Use This.
Uh I challenged that and I am going to
use it. I'm just going to cut out.
If you thought I can make it a video
without using the magic switch, you are
wrong.
And let's add some space echo on that.
I think I'm going to add it onto this
part here.
Getting far and behind.
All right. I think I'm going to just
like mess around with just some like
sounds on the guitar and just try to
manipulate them in any kind of weird way
I can. I think that's the last thing I'm
going to do here.
I got no sympath.
>> All right. I know that sounded like it
was just a bunch of random noises. It
was. But what I'm going to do, I'm going
to go through each one and just like
chop it really interestingly. I don't
know how yet. And then I'm going to mix
this. and then we're going to listen to
it. But I uh I don't know what this is
going to turn into. I'm very very
excited about this real quick. Look at
this freaking sleepy guy.
Oh my gosh. It's like I don't want to
play this song now because of how sleepy
he is. All right, so now let's go ahead
and take a listen to everything. Again,
a full mix breakdown and production
breakdown will be available on my
Patreon. link is in the description.
Thank you so so much again to Nudest
Audio for the nudest store because this
song would not be anything without the
nudest store genuinely. Uh oh, and one
more thing I did. I just took the very
speed pitch and speed down by 1% just to
add a little cool flavor on here. And
this is the final result I give you.
What's the song called again? I don't
know. Insert title right here.
city on the deep end.
I'm trying to pretend.
I'm running from what I feel the most.
I'm running fast, but it's getting
close.
When the lights come on,
Falling fast. I'm rushing. Don't know
where to begin. Feeling like I'm falling
through. I haven't got a car. I'm
running from what I feel the most.
I'm running fast cuz it's all I know.
When the lights come on
Heat. Heat.
Heat.
Holy smokes, dude. This is one of the
most fun I've had working on a song on
this channel, I think. genuinely like
man it's just so good to shake things up
from the way that I usually do them and
just to try something new. I recommend
that for all creators you know whether
you're a painter a writer you know right
outside your comfort zone paid outside
of your comfort zone make music outside
of what you usually do and outside of
your comfort zone because this has truly
brought me so much happiness. I kept
saying a few times like if no one else
likes this, it's okay because I like it.
Mainly because I've been really insecure
about what I've been making on the
channel lately. You know, I give a huge
about music production and about
sharing with others how to find a
process for music production. Mainly
because I want other people to feel what
I feel making it, you know, and that's
what the music production boot camp is
about. That's what my Patreon is about.
just other ways that I can help people
find their inner creativity so they can
feel like this the way I do right now.
But I hope that you guys enjoyed this
video. If you did, I hope you consider
subscribing and sticking around. And as
always, I will see you in the next
video. Peace.